I am Nicholas be with reason TV and we
are at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and
we're talking now to Timothy sandifer of
the Pacific Legal Foundation he helped
craft many of the arguments that went
all the way to the Supreme Court against
Obamacare are there any legal remedies
to Obamacare that are still likely to
pan out I think so there are several
lawsuits still proceeding including one
the Pacific Legal Foundation is
litigating right now that argues that
okay assuming that it is a tax it's
still unconstitutional because it did
not originate in the House of
Representatives as required by the
Constitution but then is that just a
quick fix let's let's assume that that
goes all the way up and yeah you win the
case and then is it going to get rubber
stamp somehow I don't think so not with
a Congress that is now repeatedly
expressed its dissatisfaction with the
statute and with public opinion
continuing to grow against Obamacare you
know lord knows it would be great if
Obamacare got struck down but if you get
it on a kind of technicality is that
really you know is is that good for the
country in the long run I think if that
were to occur possibly not but I don't
see it that way what I the way I see is
that the several lawsuits that are
continuing our part of an overall
challenge that has to continue to be
made both in the in the courts as well
as among policymakers and political
leaders and the effort to change the
system and reform it for the better has
to be like i like to say part of this
complete breakfast my job as an attorney
is to bring the constitutional and legal
arguments but then policymakers have to
craft better policies and political
leaders have to lead change
democratically speaking so i see what we
do as part of an overall movement that
that has to convince people to find a
way to open up consumer power to open up
free markets and to remedy our our
medical system in a free market
direction and and of course it's true
that i mean the way obamacare has been
implemented now is throw a lot of weird
glitches where we're not going to worry
about the technicalities because the
only the little people care about that
and apparently technicalities mean just
following the law itself but now you're
also working on another case that has
you really jazzed up talk a little bit
about this this is about the need for
certain types of certificates necessary
or under current law or current
interpretation
Laufer interstate moving actually yes
within States so most states in the
country have laws called certificate of
public convenience and necessity
requirements and these are licensing
laws that you're required to get a
license in order to run a moving company
taxi cabs or limousines or even
hospitals have to get these kind of
license and so this is not an interstate
issue this is an intrastate that's right
that's right and the what these laws say
is they have nothing to do with whether
you're skilled or competent or qualified
at your job what it's what these laws
say is you can't go into business until
you first proved to the government that
there needs to be a new moving company
or taxicab company or whatever and the
existing moving companies or taxicab
companies are allowed to intervene and
block you from getting a license so this
is similar to certificate of needs for
new hospitals or expansion of existing
hospitals you know this sounds like a
stupid policy wherever it is but is it a
legal one I don't think so I think it
violates the 14th amendment at least
when it comes to normal competitive
markets but now they control even
perfectly competitive ordinary markets
like moving companies so we are
challenging laws like this in Kentucky
and in Nevada in Kentucky we recently
got an injunction against a state
enforcing those laws until we have an
opportunity to prove at trial that when
you look at the facts these laws have
never been used to protect the public
and have always been used to protect
established businesses against having to
compete fairly we've been talking with
the Pacific legal foundations legal
eagle Timothy sandifer at Freedom Fest
in Las Vegas Tim thanks for talking to
us for reason TV i'm nicholas p
you